shijaz ms has had a busy few weeks
he's helped hundreds of covert 19
patients for free in the southern city
of kochi since the pandemic began
demand for his services has increased
since cases started rising a few weeks
ago
now many covet patients and their
families call me when they need any help
like taking them to hospital vaccination
getting food etc there are others who
volunteer to help me do this and many
locals have pitched in to help me with
the expenses
the southern state of kerala has
recorded its highest single day increase
since march 2020.
every second person testing for the
virus in its capital is positive
the government has imposed new
restrictions
more school classes are being held
online cinemas and gyms have closed and
public events have been banned
hospital admissions have gone up across
the state and its death toll is one of
the highest in india
rajneesh is mourning the loss of his
father who recently died from kobe 19
despite being fully vaccinated
we managed during the first wave but the
second wave was difficult for poor
people like us
now during the third wave we have lost
our father
we don't know what to do my mother is
really upset because of covert protocols
we barely got a glimpse of him when we
took his body for cremation
other states are seeing new infections
steadily decline
in western india maharashtra has
reopened schools two weeks earlier than
planned
new cases in its capital mumbai have
dropped to the lowest levels in weeks
what i think is that the metropolis has
already seen the peak and we are seeing
a downward steady downward trend in most
of the big cities but what is still
there is the b-class cities and the
villages the cases have been really
reported to be less so what i'm
expecting is that
we might be india as a country might
peak in the next one or two weeks
new delhi has imposed the highest number
of restrictions but is expected to ease
some soon and later this week
authorities will decide whether to
extend a ban on political rallies and
public meetings as voters in several
states head for the polls
pharvani mithal al-jazeera new delhi